en el vídeo anterior estábamos tratando
de resolver este problema de que en
principio parecía un problema de
triángulos y que teníamos que usar la
ley de cosenos pero esencialmente
llegamos a un problema de polinomios de
tratar de simplificar polinomios
manipularlos y demás y después de varias
operaciones bastante bastante largas lo
que tuvimos es que pudimos expresar la
raíz de 3 como un cociente de polinomios
verdad este de orden 4 este de grado 4
perdón dividido entre este producto de
dos polinomios de grado 2 eso lo hace un
polinomio de grado 4 entonces de entrada
y es muy complicado de resolver pero
bueno lo que decíamos es vamos a ver si
de alguna forma podemos cancelar algo de
aquí miren este cociente nos está
diciendo que quizás podemos intentar
factorizar este polinomio en el
numerador y cancelarlo con alguno de los
que están con los que están acá abajo
perdón entonces por ejemplo este de aquí
es muy fácil de simplificar de hecho no
se puede simplificar porque sus raíces
son complejas y tuvo utilizar la fórmula
general donde la fórmula general donde
las raíces están dadas por menos b más
menos la raíz de b cuadrada menos 4 hace
entre 2 a esa si tú utilizas esa fórmula
con este polinomio las raíces que
resultan ser complejas entonces a éste
no no se ve como que se puede manejar
muy bien sin embargo este polinomio de
aquí el x cuadrada menos 1 este de aquí
lo podemos factorizar como x + 1 x x
menos 1 muy bien y si podemos factorizar
lo de esta forma eso significa que a lo
mejor uno y menos uno podrían ser raíces
de este polinomio de acá arriba y la
verdad es que nos sentimos muy bien y
muy cómodos por lo siguiente supongan sé
que por ejemplo tenemos un polinomio de
esta forma x menos r 1 por x menos r 2
por xr3 y para que sea de grado 4 vamos
a multiplicar por x menos r4 r1 r2 r3 y
r4 son las raíces de este polinomio
entonces a la hora de multiplicarlo pues
esto nos va a dar x a la 4 más quien
sabe qué cosas blablabla y el último
término es r1 r2 r3 r4 muy bien entonces
si nos damos cuenta este último término
es la multiplicación no tiene que ver
con la multiplicación de las raíces y en
nuestro caso particular son números
enteros y tenemos un 1 y bueno tenemos
aquí un 2 pero si dividimos todo entre 2
ok tendríamos aquí algo así como un
medio entonces este de aquí sería
digamos un medio que dividiendo este
polinomio entre 2 en nuestro caso
particular el producto de las raíces
debería ser más o menos bueno no esto no
es una prueba formal de lo que estoy
diciendo solo es una técnica de cómo
podríamos ir visualizando esto y el
producto debería ser un medio eso nos
dice que pues hay como
mucha oportunidad de que uno o menos uno
sea raíz muy bien entonces lo que
tenemos que ver es si este polinomio de
aquí arriba se puede factorizar con x +
1 x menos 1 muy bien entonces déjenme
quitar todo esto que hemos hecho no lo
vamos a ocupar ahorita
y vamos a ver si son raíces el 1 y el
menos 1 es decir si al evaluar el
polinomio en 1 o en menos 1 esto se
anula vamos a ver qué pasaría si
nosotros evaluamos este en digamos en 1
entonces tenemos 2 x 1 a la 4 que es dos
más dos por uno al cubo que es otro dos
menos tres por uno al cuadrado
entonces menos 3 por 1 al cuadrado es
menos tres menos dos por uno es menos
dos y sumamos uno muy bien entonces esto
nos da dos más dos son cuatro menos tres
es uno menos dos es que llevábamos uno
menos dos es menos uno más uno es cero
entonces uno puede raíz tenemos ya una
raíz este es un factor del polinomio de
que está en el numerador vamos a ver qué
pasa con menos 1 tenemos 2 x menos 1 a
la 4 - 1 a la 4 es 1 entonces tenemos 2
más 2 por menos 1 al cubo menos 1 al
cubo es menos 1 entonces tenemos en
realidad un -2 ahora menos 3 x menos 1
al cuadrado es menos tres menos 2 x
menos 1 es más 2 y sumamos 1 y eso nos
queda 2 menos 12 0 menos tres más dos
son menos uno más uno es cero entonces
también x menos uno es una raíz perdón
es es un factor es un factor
que está en el numerador así que si
nosotros dividimos el numerador entre
este entre x + 1 por x menos uno que el
producto es x cuadrada menos 1 debería
tener un residuo cero es decir expresar
lo de otra forma vamos a hacer eso ya
tenemos un muy buen avance ok entonces
aquí viene la parte interesante en donde
es un muy buen ejercicio para practicar
división de polinomios no la división
larga de polinomios y vamos a dividir x
cuadrada menos 1 entre perdón más bien
sería vamos a dividir sería dividir
esencialmente es lo que estoy diciendo
pero es vamos a dividir 2 x a la 4 2 x
al cubo menos 3 x cuadrada menos 2 x más
1 lo vamos a dividir entre x cuadrada
menos 1 ok entonces nos preguntamos
cuántas veces kdx cuadrada en 2 x a la 4
y eso es 2 veces x cuadrada verdad vamos
a ponerlo aquí donde está la equis
cuadrada y eso es bueno si multiplicamos
ahora es 2x cuadrada por x cuadrada es 2
x a la 4 verdad y luego 2x cuadradas x
menos 1 es menos 2x cuadrada
multiplicamos por menos para restar los
verdad los restamos y aquí nos va a dar
menos aquí más estos se cancelan y nos
quedan 2 x al cubo vamos a ponerlo con
rojo
vamos a ponerlo con rojo y nos queda 2x
al cubo y menos tres más dos son menos 1
x cuadrada
digamos vamos a bajar el resto verdad
ahora cuántas veces cabe x cuadrada en 2
x al cubo
pues eso cabe 2x veces verdad tenemos
que multiplicar por 2 x 2 x x x cuadrada
es justamente 2 x al cubo 2 x x menos 1
es menos 2x y nuevamente como vamos a
restar entonces cambiamos el signo
ponemos un menos y aquí uno más
estos se cancelan estos también y nos
queda simplemente menos equis cuadrada
más 1 y entonces vemos que en realidad x
cuadrada menos 1 cabe menos una vez
verdad ponemos menos 1 por x cuadrada es
menos x cuadrada menos 1 x menos 1 es
más uno y entonces esto es exactamente
igual el residuo es cero cosa que ya
sabíamos que iba a pasar porque vimos
que x1 y x1 son factores y al
multiplicarlos bueno es x cuadrada menos
1 hacemos esta división y no
y cuánto nos queda es decir lo que estoy
diciendo es que esencialmente esto esto
de aquí arriba lo podemos ver de la
siguiente forma
tenemos el 2x cuadrada + 2 x 1 que si lo
multiplicamos por x cuadrada menos 1
por equis cuadrada menos 1 es
exactamente esto que está en el
numerador pero ahora la ventaja que
tenemos es que tenemos estos dos
factores que se pueden cancelar se
pueden cancelar muy bien y sólo nos
queda esta división de dos polinomios de
segundo grado muy bien y eso es muy a
todo dar es muy muy agradable y qué
bueno que salió así porque resolver
ecuaciones de segundo grado eso sí
podemos hacerlo esencialmente que es lo
que hay que hacer vamos a pasar este
polinomio amarillo multiplicando con el
raíz de 3 y qué es lo que nos va a
quedar
tenemos la raíz de 3 que multiplica x
cuadrada más la raíz de 3 que multiplica
x más la raíz de 3 que multiplica 1 y
esto cómo pasó multiplicando nos debe de
nos debe dar igual a este polinomio que
tenemos acá arriba esto es igual esto es
igual a 2 x cuadrada más 12 x
- 1 muy bien y bueno pues tú dirás bueno
eso no es una ecuación de las que yo
conozco entonces todo el morado lo vamos
a pasar del lado izquierdo entonces
tendremos raíz de 3 menos 2 por equis
cuadrada verdad como estamos restando
digamos todo esto poco lo estamos
pasando del lado izquierdo con signo
menos y tenemos raíz de 3 menos 2 que
multiplica x cuadrada es este término y
este término
la raíz de 3 - dos verdades este y este
que multiplica x y finalmente tenemos la
raíz de tres más uno verdad porque si
sumamos uno de ambos lados aquí se
cancelan y queda del lado izquierdo como
más 1 y esto debe ser igual a 0 y ahora
sí tenemos una ecuación de segundo grado
que es muy fácil de resolver quizás no
es trivial porque pueden ser operaciones
complicadas pero sabemos cómo resolverlo
nuestras dos soluciones están dadas de
la siguiente forma
- ve que en este caso es este es b
entonces menos esto sería dos menos la
raíz de tres más menos la raíz de b
cuadrada que es raíz de tres menos dos
al cuadrado menos cuatro por a
qué es este raíz de tres menos dos por c
qué raíz de tres más uno muy bien y todo
eso hay que dividirlo entre dos por a
entre dos por la raíz de tres menos dos
muy bien y así que como ves hago aún no
tenemos completamente resuelto el
problema ya podrás al menos darte cuenta
de que los que hicieron el examen no se
andan con problemas fáciles aquí vamos a
dejarlo porque ya nos acercamos a los
diez minutos y necesito de verdad un
vaso con agua probablemente es el
problema más agotador que he hecho en mi
vida terminaremos esto en el siguiente
vídeo